lo que quiero hacer en este video es
explorar la mecánica de una hipoteca de
tasa ajustable típica y después
contemplar En cuáles situaciones esto
podría ser ventajoso y En cuáles
situaciones pues no lo sería tanto al
menos para las personas que compran
inmuebles primero veamos cómo funciona
esto voy a dibujar una línea del
tiempo Aquí vamos a tener nuestra tasa
de interés que es un
porcentaje y también voy a dibujar en el
eje
horizontal mi tiempo que va a estar en
años ahora voy a ponerle la escala a
cada
eje en el eje de la tasa de interés voy
a tener
1%
2%
3%
4% 5% y 6% y podría aumentar más ahora
en el eje del tiempo en años voy a tener
un
dos
tres
cuatro
cco 6 años y antes de ponerme a dibujar
lo que es la hipoteca de tasa ajustable
o variable pensemos en cómo funciona una
hipoteca de tasa fija si yo tengo una
hipoteca de tasa fija pues se va a
comportar exactamente como dice su
nombre la taza va a estar
fija quizá la las tasas de interés en el
momento en el que se establece la
hipoteca dependiendo del tipo de
préstamo que se tenga y el historial
crediticio digamos que se tiene una tasa
fija del
4% eso significa que durante la vida de
nuestro préstamo nuestro préstamo tendrá
una tasa fija del 4% cualquiera que sea
la cantidad que te debemos de pagar
sobre el capital que tengamos en
cualquier momento pagaremos el
equivalente del 4% de tasa anual y ya
hemos hablado en detalle al respecto en
otros
videos hablamos de hipotecas de tasa
fija para 15 20 o 30 años y ustedes
podrían decir bueno conforme pase el
tiempo yo voy a estar pagando cada vez
más capital lo que significa que cada
uno de mis pagos una mayor proporción
irá a pagar el interés por lo que yo no
siento que mi tasa de interés cambie Y
esto es cierto hasta cierto punto la
tasa de interés a la que estamos pagando
lo que queda del capital del
va siendo constante y en este eemplo va
ser una constante va ser un 4% constante
y ahora ha con hipot DEA aable pues
comoes se imaginar t de interés va ajar
as una hipot de tasa ajustable podí Com
en un
2% yo lucir muy bien pero la en la que
esto va auncion Es que en tasas de
interés a corto plazo si la tasa de
interés a corto plazo aumenta la tasa
ajustable de la hipoteca también va a
aumentar y podría ser una realidad que
la hipoteca de tasa ajustable crezca
tanto que sea incluso mayor que la tasa
fija Y si esto creciera
dramaticamente esa tasa ajustable de la
hipoteca también crecería dramáticamente
a qué me refiero con que crezcan las
tasas de interés a corto plazo Bueno
cuando tenemos una hipoteca de tasa
ajustable normalmente se ajusta usando
alguna tasa índice en Estados Unidos el
índice más común a usar son los bonos
del tesoro a corto plazo son estos bonos
que tiene que pagar el gobierno cuando
el gobierno le pide a sus ciudadanos
prestado Durante un año Así que son
bonos del tesoro a un año Aunque Podrían
haber otros índices ocultos otro índice
típico que se usa para para cualquier
préstamo con tasa
ajustable no solo las hipotecas sino
cualquier tipo de préstamo incluso
préstamos
corporativos podría ser la tasa de
oferta interbancaria de Londres conocida
como libor por sus siglas en inglés y
hay otros videos en donde explico A qué
se refiere este
índice sin embargo digamos que estamos
tratando con hipotecas de tasa ajustable
que se basan en bonos del tesoro a un
año y con Respecto a los bonos del
tesoro ha un mercado para estos Y estos
cambian de un día para
ot supongamos que este es el diagrama de
lo que Ur con estos
bonos de estos bos del tesoro que duran
un año durante too este
tiempo esto quiere decir queo en este
momento del tiempo si les prestamos
dinero al gobierno Durante un año
obtendremos el 2% de interés
la tasa de préstamo del gobierno es del
2% y es bastante poco común que
cualquier prestamista de la misma tasa
de interés que el
gobierno el gobierno puede imprimir
dinero y dispone del crédito de los
Estados Unidos y esto no es algo que
cualquier persona pueda tener una
persona que recibe un préstamo puede
tener problemas para devolverlo para
pagarlo así que no se va a tener
Exactamente esa tasa de interés Será esa
tasa de interés más un porcentaje más
pero imaginemos que tenemos un muy buen
crédito Así que nuestra tasa de interés
será del
1% y esto Bueno solo las compañías muy
bien establecidas pueden tener este tipo
de tasas de interés solo lo hacemos para
no complicarnos con los cálculos
matemáticos Y ustedes pueden ver que en
el momento en el que se hizo el préstamo
el porcentaje del Bono de tesoro era de
1% así que nosotros vamos a tener un 2%
y la forma en la que funciona esta tasa
ajustable es que cada periodo quizás
cada 6 meses o cada año se va a
reestablecer la tasa si tenemos una
hipoteca de tasa ajustable que se va a
restablecer cada año que se ajusta
anualmente Así es como vamos a tener
este
ejemplo Así que aquí tenemos el 2% para
el primer año del tiempo c al primer año
y en ese punto se van a fijar en cómo
está el índice y digamos que ahora el
índice está en 1.6
por. por lo que se va a pagar un 1%
adicional a esto por lo que estaremos
pagando 2.6 por. y Esto será para el
segundo año y ahora las tasas de interés
a corto plazo han aumentado más se están
acercando a tres ahora vamos a pagar un
un interés del 4% en este escenario en
donde nuestras tasas de interés han
estado aumentando continuamente nuestra
tasa de la hipoteca se está Ajustando
cada año hacia
arriba y vemos Que para ese tercer año
ya estamos pagando casi lo mismo que en
la tasa fija pero me pueden decir Bueno
pues todavía esto es positivo ya que los
otros años anteriores pagué una tasa de
interés menor en los primeros dos años
pagué menos interés que la tasa fija y
es apenas hasta el tercer año que ya
estoy pagando lo mismo y es cierto para
este ejemplo en este caso sí ha
funcionado bastante bien pero en el
tercer año las tasas de interés aumentan
más y Tendremos que ajustarnos también
hacia arriba Así que nuestra tasa
ajustable podría llegar hasta aquí
arriba y en este año nuestra tasa de
interés es mayor que la tasa de interés
fija la tasa de interés que se aplica al
capital que estamos pagando aumentado Y
en este caso yo dibujé un escenario en
el que se va a volver más favorable para
nosotros conforme pase el tiempo por lo
que esa tasa se puede ajustar hacia
abajo aquí estamos pagando más que la
tasa fija pero en el siguiente año
volvemos a pagar un poco menos y este
solo es uno de muchos escenarios que
pueden ocurrir y Pueden decir Bueno pues
en la mayoría de los años estuve pagando
menos que la tasa fija lo cual me
conviene pero recuerden que este es solo
uno de muchos escenarios posibles quizás
la inflación enloquece y este índice se
comporta así que no es lo típico y no es
algo que sea probable que ocurra pero sí
ha ocurrido con anterioridad sobre todo
cuando se han tenido periodos
inflacionarios muy altos y con algo así
ustedes pueden ver que su hipoteca de
tasa ajustable se va a disparar y
existen mecanismos que impiden que una
tasa hipotecaria aumente más de cierto
porcentaje más del 1 o 2% anual Pero si
ustedes ven algo así o algo que aumenta
constantemente como esto significa que
durante la vida del préstamo
especialmente si ustedes tienen un
préstamo para muchos años 10 15 20 años
podrían tener que pagar una cantidad
sustancial de intereses Por otra parte
es muy probable que este índice se
comporte sí las tasas de interés se
comportan así durante todo el periodo
del préstamo en cuyo caso la hipoteca de
tasa ajustable va a ser mucho más
conveniente ustedes pueden notar un
patrón aquí con la hipoteca de tasa fija
es bastante predecible lo que se va a
pagar esto es
predecible sabemos con seguridad qué es
lo que vamos a estar pagando mes con mes
mientras que con la tasa ajustable va a
ser mucho menos predecible lo que vamos
a tener que estar
pagando menos predecible y esto nos trae
una idea bastante interesante que se
llama el riesgo de la tasa de interés la
cual quizás ustedes hayan escuchado
hablar sobre todo en las redes donde
hablan de finanzas o si leen la sección
de finanzas del periódico riesgo de tasa
de interés y este es el riesgo que uno
lleva Si es que aumentan dramáticamente
las tasas de interés si se tiene una
hipoteca de tasa ajustable Cuál va a ser
el riesgo Bueno este riesgo va a estar
relacionado a si es que la tasa de
interés aumenta mucho entonces el pago
va a aumentar y bueno con una hipoteca
de tasa fija Quién tiene el riesgo quién
lleva este
riesgo Pues en este caso el banco es el
que lleva el riesgo y quién lleva el
riesgo en el escenario de la hipoteca de
tasa ajustable pues va a ser el
prestatario mientras que en la tasa fija
quién lleva el riesgo Pues en este caso
va a ser el
prestamista el
prestamista Por qué es que el
prestamista toma el riesgo Pues porque
cuando ellos le prestan algo a alguien
con una tasa de interés fija que nuestra
ejemplo es de
4% si el interés fuera a crecer
dramáticamente Recuerden que muchos
prestamistas especialmente instituciones
financieras como los bancos están
tomando prestado dinero también de dónde
están tomando ese dinero prestado pues
de muchas Fuentes una de ellas es de las
personas que están haciendo depósitos
recuerden lo que hacen los bancos Este
es el banco aquí las personas les hacen
depósitos
depósitos que hemos visto con más
detalle en otros videos los cuales
después son
prestados van en préstamos cuando los
bancos reciben depósitos lo que
normalmente hacen es prometer intereses
y cuando ellos hacen préstamos también
van a recibir
intereses y bueno Esto está fijo pero si
nuestra tasa de interés las tasas de
interés a corto plazo aumentaran
entonces estarán pagando más de lo que
están recibiendo esto no está cambiando
mientras Esto está aumentando por lo que
no van a estar recibiendo tanto dinero
así que el riesgo de la tasa de interés
en la hipoteca de tasa ajustable es el
prestatario quien tiene el riesgo en
cambio en la tasa fija va a ser el
prestamista el que va a tener el
riesgo